awesome so let's start from the
beginning david
um it's a very good place to start
okay perfect so let's pretend i just
introduced you everything is working out
perfectly welcome to everyone to the
meetup and now david it looks great on
zoom that we'll see there you go
um
okay so from the top right i think the
the goal here is to provide an overview
of the the different components of our
studio team and how they can support the
work you're doing in python uh so i'll
give a quick sort of overview of those
three components and then we'll jump
into sort of trying to solve some
problems that you might confront as a
data scientist with them um and so just
to outline what they are and again i'll
stress that they do work independently
um so you should feel free to
consider the ones that work specifically
for for your uh collection of problems
right
our studio workbench is going to give
you um ids right so places to develop
and build that code right
so the rstudio ide which is you know
uh which you can use to edit python code
there's some functionality that's been
built in there to support doing that
as well as more python native editors
like jupiter or vs code right so that's
going to give you all those options uh
connect is going to be where you share
things with people who you wouldn't
expect to be working in a development
environment so
uh you know applications you built with
shiny or python frameworks like dash or
streamlet
apis so if you're trying to
facilitate machine to machine
communication or reports or documents
that you want to share
perhaps on some kind of regular schedule
and then supporting those two services
and where we'll start kind of walking
through
you know how these things can be used as
package manager which is going to give
you the ability to bring those open
source repositories inside your network
which solves an important networking
kind of constraint that some teams have
it gives you the ability to serve your
own internal packages so if you've
already got a development ecosystem of
those things then you can you can serve
those from package manager and
and it's going to make it possible for
you to impose some reproducibility
governance um and so i think the the
first thing that i i'll i'll sort of
focus on right is um
using some of the the functionality that
exists in package manager um to make
your to have an easier time reproducing
your project when something unexpected
happens um
and the the example i want to use to
highlight that uh is thinking about uh
this this kind of change that happened
last week in streamlit
where one of the underlying libraries
that supports streamlit
called protobuf
sort of made a change and that change
resulted in lots of breaking streamlight
applications
and people had to kind of figure out
that they needed to pin their
dependencies to a version of of protobuf
that doesn't sort of have the changed
behavior um and so that's that's one way
of going about solving the problem of
you know
you know specifying an environment
that's going to work for your project
the thing i want to show in package
manager is that you have some other
options um for
reusing functionality that we built
for r to make your project easier to
reproduce and so in particular i'm
talking about this kind of date-based
snapshotting model that we make
available right if i select um
you know today the latest date right
which is today then what we're going to
get is you know just pi pi as it exists
at the moment right um and so if we
wanted to uh say be able to reproduce
the uh the error as people were
experiencing it on the on the 26th uh
then we can use um sort of this date
based snapshot and so when we call pip
install right if we were to call it in
this way with this index url pointing to
this date-based snapshot of the
repository
then that request is going to be
resolved by package manager as if it
were the 26th and so you'll see that
in a in a library where we have that
configured we're actually going to end
up with the same uh breakage that other
people were experiencing but a nice
thing that we can do is you know roll
let's say you know configure our
repository so that it points to a
previous week and that's going to give
us a little bit more um you know it's
going to
give us unblock us from sort of getting
our project uh out and deployed and so
i'm going to jump over to our studio
workbench um
to show you what that looks like this is
kind of the landing page for our studio
workbench um if you wanted to start up
additional sessions right you would be
sort of opening up this launcher pane
you have the ability to select from
those different editors as i mentioned
another thing i won't spend as much time
on today right but you have the the
option of running uh your sessions um in
the context of some external cluster
resource manager uh and in this case
we're using kubernetes and that gives us
a little bit of finer grain control uh
over the resources available to an
individual session uh but also this this
thing that i find really convenient is
the ability to select different images
for that workload um and so that you
know
if you can imagine if you have say like
operating system
level reproducibility requirements or
something that that happens sometimes or
if you just have uh workloads that are
different enough that it's useful to
express them as different container
images um then this can be a nice way of
making those things available um
in the workbench context
and so i'll open up in this case vs code
um
and the you know what i'll show you is
right like if you've used vs code
locally on your desktop the experience
you're seeing you're seeing here is
going to be pretty similar
so i opened up a new terminal window
i'll make this a little bit bigger
um
and
i've opened up a new terminal window uh
we're what we're going to see right is
you know we've got the
we've got the code for a streamlit app
uh when i opened up this terminal i
automatically activated this virtual
environment um the thing i'll also show
you here is i've created a virtual
environment that specifically
uh has the um
uh has my pi pi repository set
to
to install packages as if it were the
26th and so if i um
activate that virtual environment
instead
uh and attempt to streamline run
uh my app
right what we're gonna see is we're
gonna
have the app sort of blow up on that
same protobuf error uh that people were
experiencing right and so
the way you can tell that um
the pip configuration is set uh that way
in this case is i'm going to call pit
config and i've set the site
configuration which just means it's
configured for this virtual this is
configured for this virtual environment
i'll type list right and what you should
see is that the global index url uh is
going to be set for uh
pi pi on that specific date right so you
see global index url uh
colorado.studio.com which is where we
keep our server right pointing to that
date
i'll get rid of that
yeah quality on zoom 2 probably just
zoom in a little bit
sure um if that's okay
cool
thank you
so no problem and so let's activate our
standard virtual environment
um
and so
now if i try to streamlets run the
application and i think i actually have
the streamlit running application here
right um then you'll see that we kind of
get the the startup you're expecting
um
but if we want to view this application
before we start thinking about pushing
it anywhere and this is kind of a
workbench extension that we provide for
working with vs code
one of the one of the things that's
going to be different from doing uh
development in this browser context as
opposed to doing it locally
is that you know lots of things when
you're doing this local development
expect to be able to kind of call
themselves on on a locally running web
server
and we have to do a little bit of extra
work to make sure that you can find
those applications in the context of
that remotely running server and so this
proxy servers view in our studio
workbench just sort of finds when you
start an application um and then serves
its location up to you here so that when
i click it um it's going to to redirect
me out to the the streamlit application
uh that should be loading there
right and so that's how we can uh sort
of do some of the development work that
we would be uh
sort of doing normally on a on a local
context
so that's uh you know uh package manager
sort of
behind the scenes right supporting you
being able to configure uh different
development enviro uh you know different
uh sort of virtual environments that
have
you know sort of different database
snapshots and that's going to make
things a lot easier
to deal with once we have um
you know once we've got got the
application in a place where we're ready
to share it with people um then the next
thing we're going to want to think about
doing is deployment
and so i'll walk through what the
process of using the command line
interface that um
is distributed on pi pi called rs
connect python if you wanted to get that
on your machine you would pip install
rs connect python
and that's going to give you
this rs connect command line interface
if i type help
right then we're going to get a bunch of
information about the the different
things that this command line interface
can do
i'm going to close this window so we get
a little bit more space
um and so yeah we've got a bunch of
different things uh these top level
commands right we can uh enter we can
set the command line interface up to
interact with a bunch of different
servers uh so in this case if i list the
configured servers i have you know one
connection set up to to the server will
be deploying to uh then i could have you
know additional servers if i had a
development
you know development server or
pre-production server where i needed to
deploy things for
user acceptance testing or things of
that nature um
if i look at the help for deploy right
and we're going to see a bunch of
information about again the different
types of content that are supported by
connect for deployment right so api and
fast api are going to give you uh
synchronous and asynchronous python
servers respectively right they're not
totally uh general right um but for lots
of flask apps or if you're building
things based on like fast api or starlit
if you're familiar with that or quartz
or sanic there are a couple of different
options that we support on on the on the
api side to make it possible for you to
deploy lots of different kinds of things
uh bokeh dash and streamlit uh are going
to be you know those application
frameworks that make it easy for you to
you know share visualizations and things
like that
the command line interface also supports
uh behind the scenes the deployment of
jupiter notebooks which i'll show
from jupiter in a second um and then one
kind of nice bonus right is that if you
have a manifest file which is kind of
our
connect specific deployment artifact
i'll show you what that looks like here
it has a bit of information
about what you need to get your
application deployed but if you have one
of those in the repository already then
you can use the command line interface
to deploy those things and the nice
thing about that is that that works with
content even if that content is our only
you can use the command line interface
to get that deployed
so in this case i'm going to
deploy
streamlit application
looking at the help for streamlets
um
and so we're just gonna need a couple of
things uh to to get this off our machine
and shared with everybody else right and
so in particular um we're going to need
to provide the the directory right where
this lives they're going to be a couple
of extra files here uh we're going to
need to provide the
the name of the target server
and then we're also going to specify the
path to the python interpreter just to
make it uh sort of explicit where we're
getting our dependencies from
so i'm going to deploy streamlets
streamlab current directory
to the target server
with a specified python interpreter
and that's not it's a dash p
um
and so the process we're going through
here to get this deployed
is going to be kind of conceptually
similar no matter what you're deploying
to connect right which is we're going to
create a bundle um of the files we've
specified
and something that enumerates the
requirements that we have to build this
on the server right in this case that's
going to be the requirements file right
which lays out um what i you know what
dependencies i need in order to rebuild
this application on the connect server
so we're going to turn those things into
a bundle we're going to send them to the
connect server
connect receives the bundle and then
it's going to use that to rebuild the
environment
and it's going to rebuild that
environment in an isolated way which is
going to be very convenient for you
because you know
it it supports deploying things built
with multiple versions of python uh
potentially conflicting system uh con
excuse me potentially conflicting
packages right you can have different
versions uh say applications built with
different versions of streamlit and
those can all
live simultaneously on the connect
server and so it's a it's going to give
you a lot of freedom in terms of
experimentation
and just like being able to deploy
things without worrying about taking
other things down
and so this is gonna
take a second to deploy uh while that
happens let me pause rachel any
questions i should answer or should i
keep rolling
yeah let me
um check over to the slido and to
youtube here
thank you all again for switching over
with us and
and bearing with us through any
technical difficulties here
as a reminder
you can also ask questions anonymously
through slido and so
i'll ask tom hanna tyler to share that
in youtube as well
but the short link is just
rstd
dot io
slash
meetups
questions
and i'm sure they're sharing that in the
youtube chat right now
let's see i'll go over to the team who's
helping me over here on slack do you see
any questions on
youtube yet
see
don't see any yet from the team
um one question i just had david if if
people want to follow along with some of
these examples that you're sharing
um where's the the best place to get
those or could you share that github
link
that's an excellent leading question
that's the next link i have here so all
of the examples uh like all the um
there are a bunch of as i mentioned
different types of things you can deploy
to connect uh that are python based uh
and so we have this repository um
at you know github.com solange python
examples and that's just going to give
you all you know all of these different
types of of content so streamlit apps uh
flask apps reticulated apps so that's
apps where you say you have a shiny
front end but a lot of the work is being
done by python fast api flask we've
really got sort of everything there so
you know feel free to fork this repo um
the examples we try as hard as we can to
keep them deployable right so if you
need say something to test on your own
connect server and fork the repo
and deploy it uh to your connect server
just as a way of um
you know understanding uh sort of the
different capabilities that uh
that connect has for supporting python
content
awesome there's a few questions that
came on came through slido
and one was i configure my python
environment using conda can i use conda
with rstudio connect
you
uh the answer is sort of right so i
think connect uh connects for focus is
on um
where connect does the best is kind of
with uh with packages that are on pi pi
um so you can use conda to manage your
environments uh and if the packages that
you're using are available on pipi
then it should be reasonably
straightforward to restore um there
there are ways of getting connects to
restore
packages that might not be available
from pi pi that's a little bit more
involved it's going to involve some
collaboration and coordination with your
administrator to make that work um
so yeah i i think sort of our workflow
is pretty like pi pi centered at the
moment
okay thank you and one other question
that came through was um will django be
supported
um
i i am not the right person to ask about
whether uh django will be supported what
i would say is that you know i think
django
uh
tries to do a much bigger set of things
and is uh
then is like the modal or the typical
thing that a data scientist is trying to
build an app to do right there's like
you know part of i think what connect
makes so easy is like some of the
concerns around
uh user management or things like that
where where django is trying to be like
a a truly sort of full stack web
framework um so
um you know people ask occasionally and
i think uh it's something that we can
sort of monitor the interest in but
right now it's uh
i'd say it's not something we're
thinking about the immediate collection
of priorities
thank you um and then one other question
i did see on youtube um was is this
presentation being recorded and made
available later
um yes one of the nice things about
youtube live is that the second that it
is the presentation's over the recording
is available at the same exact link too
but thank you david i'll turn it back
over to you
okay
um so yeah like i mentioned there are a
bunch of different python examples uh
that we have available in the repository
uh so one of the things i'll just do is
jump back to workbench um and open up uh
jupiter right which is gonna give you um
again if you're used i'm gonna use the
classic notebook notebook interface for
this example uh jupiter lab is also a
supported option um and so in this case
i've got you know an example uh it's
pretty bare bones it just runs a couple
of visualizations
and it's going to you know give you um
some plots that you could share um and
so but i think the the lesson here is or
the takeaway is that if you're if you're
somebody who likes to use jupiter to do
your data science work right um the
experience that you're going to have
right it should not be substantially
different on workbench and so it's going
to continue to be that familiar home for
you to do some of that development work
um there are really only two extensions
that uh right now that we provide in say
the jupiter classic interface one of
them is just going to take you back to
the workbench home page and then the
other one is going to support the the
publishing workflow when i clicked on
the wrong button there um that that
mirrors pretty closely what it looks
like to use the push button publishing
workflow from the rstudio ide um
and so that's just going to mean that
you know you've done some interactive
development in the notebook
you're ready to share those results with
with other people and we're going to
give you an easy way to push that
notebook to a remote server
so you can see all right i've already
configured um
my
configurations of the target server
where this is going to be deployed i'm
going to call this presentation notebook
and then for all kinds of documents that
you publish to connect and this is
excuse me both on the r and python side
you're going to have the option of
either publishing the document with
source code and that's going to unlock a
lot of the power to have connect sort of
take custody of the document uh executed
on a schedule we'll show what that looks
like in a second um but also you know if
you have you know say
either dependency conflicts that are too
complicated to resolve the connect
server or you just
you know you don't actually want to make
the source code available you can just
render the document locally and then
push it to the connect server
the reason i'm going to call this
presentation notebook is that one of
those things we enable you to do
as you're as you're publishing is
specify that you you don't actually want
people to be able to see the code in the
notebook right um so that this this hide
all input code cells there's a
corresponding flag in the command line
interface uh we'll we'll just make it be
the case that you know when this
notebook is deployed what we'll see um
is just the plots but we won't actually
see the code that generated them and so
for things that you intend to to be for
you know sharing but not necessarily you
know
a walkthrough of how you got the results
um being able to hide those cells is
really useful and you can also hide
specific cells if you tag them
and so i'll hit publish right in this
case i'm getting the new location right
new title presentation notebook
and then i'm going to publish this and i
think i need to make that smaller to hit
publish um
and so again the the process i described
as we went through deploying a streamlit
application is going to be
the same right which is we're going to
make sure we have an accounting of the
the files we need in this case it's the
python notebook files uh the
requirements that we have for
re-executing this environment right so
in addition to say jupiter right there's
also some
some numpy manipulation taking place in
this file and so we need to make sure
that that library is installed in
addition to
um
in addition to the jupyter libraries
we're going to push that over
so the connect server connect rebuilds
this notebook in an isolated environment
and then you can see we're going through
the process of rendering the notebook
and once that's done we'll have
something that's ready to present and
share with other people
and i'll say just a reminder for anybody
who missed the slido
link that we shared you can also ask
questions anonymously
if you don't want to just comment in the
youtube chat
and tom mock just shared that for us in
the youtube chat thanks tom
so
that covers um
sort of the process of getting things
from the development environment um to
connect where they're going to be shared
and so the last couple things i want to
do um is just to show you some of the
possibilities once you've deployed a
document to connect all right so in this
case you can see right the the code
required to generate these uh these
plots it's not being shown right so
you've got a notebook that's
presentation ready um one of the first
things you might want to do right is
make this a little bit easier to find
right so when you deploy a piece of
content to connect you're going to get
you know it's deployed at this unique
url which is not necessarily the most
memorable thing in the world so one of
the things we enable you to do
is set a custom content url and that's
just going to make it you know really
simple
uh give you a a memorable a place with a
more memorable name to to share that
notebook and the nice thing about that
is once uh you know
once you've generated that url if you
open up a new window and you share the
notebook with with someone there right
then they're just seeing that content
right they don't even see any of the
sort of connect
uh ui all right and so for you know
stakeholders who aren't say on your data
science team right this is going to be
probably a presentation that they must
prefer and you know you're insulating
them from like the deployment details
and you just get to get them to focus on
the results um the other thing you're
going to have control over is who's
allowed to see this notebook
and since connect sort of integrates
with you can be integrated with whatever
sort of enterprise authentication system
you're using
right
i could say add the rest of the members
of the solutions engineering team uh as
as viewers of this content i could add
specific people um i can give them
collaborator permissions which is going
to mean that they have the ability to
come in and make further modifications
uh to that document i can make the
document more permissive and say okay
you know anybody who reaches this server
will can can view this document but they
have to log in first so you get a really
wide range of um
of ways that you can share this content
with people in your enterprise
the other nice thing that you get on the
document side um is going to be the
ability to set things to run on a
schedule right so say that rather than a
notebook that's just kind of uh
read once uh you have something that you
want to run repeatedly
this is gonna you know because you are
fetching external data uh that might be
a nice way to sort of have say some
monthly reporting uh or you know on
whatever schedule is going to work for
you uh and you can set that to sort of
run on a schedule and then he'd be
emails to people you're collaborating
with or other viewers rachel i saw you
had a question yeah quick question and i
love that now we're making this very
interactive here somebody asked
they said i'm a bit actually a lot
confused they expected to see the usual
our studio r studio
um
like i imagine our studio on their
desktop but we're curious what
environment is this work being done in
so
and yeah if i was not clear enough about
that i'm sorry all right so workbench
right is gives you the option of
starting
lots of different editors so the um
the streamload applications i was
working with all right i'm working with
in vs code
which is uh
you know a pretty popular sort of editor
for doing lots of kinds of of code
editing and management uh jupiter is
going to support doing a lot of that uh
sort of notebook style development you
can edit jupyter notebooks in vs code as
well that's actually my preferred
workflow
and then
again the the rstudio ide is also sort
of available to you in work mention so
you get the full sort of range of
different things right it's a
right when we talk about it being a home
for r and python right is because
you have the ability to run both r as
well as like different python editors uh
they're you know they have access to the
same files if you do configuration for
access to databases all that all that
information is going to be sort of
consolidated in one place
awesome thank you
i think um also for for anybody who's
never even seen our studio workbench too
it might be helpful to just cover what's
the difference between workbench and
maybe the open source or studio ide
sure yeah so you know workbench has a
few different flavors right or sorry our
studio has a few different flavors right
there's the desktop ide
right which is the the open source one
that lots of people use uh i used it for
a long time before uh i work here right
and that's just gonna run on whatever uh
you know that runs on mac os that's
gonna run on windows that'll run on
linux desktop if you're if you're that
kind of person um
and then um there's the open source r
studio server which gives you the same
kind of browser-based capability that i
was talking about um so you know you can
run uh say you know
again you can drop into the r studio ide
running in the browser um there are a
few differences in terms of features and
functionality that the professional
version of the ide supports some of them
are around like uh you know auditing
auditing
uh
just like things that are going to be
single sign-on configuration things that
are going to be much more important to
um to to enterprise users and that's
where workbench comes in so there are
lots of open source ways of running like
the r studio ide they're like
docker images from the rocker project
that make that really easy i think once
people find that they need to run those
things in an enterprise context then
then workbench is where they tend to go
and so workbench supports um
you know running those multiple editors
the the things i was mentioning earlier
about running in these different
computing contexts so if you're if you
need to work in kubernetes or slurm or
some other external resource manager
then that's when you'd be looking for
some of the functionalities that
workbench provides
awesome thanks david
um and just tell me when you want me to
stop asking questions and
that's i mean that's that is the like i
think the core of the workflow right
we've seen right there's you get the
ability to manage packages from package
manager um
you you know workbench gives you a
collection of different editing
environments that you can use to to get
your work done in a way that feels
comfortable for you um and it's going to
support your team and their diverse
preferences really well uh and then
connect is going to you know be able to
run and
make it easy for you to share things
whether they're built with shiny or dash
or streamlits or what have you um so i'm
happy to just take questions for the the
remaining time we have here because i i
think that that covers sort of the basic
flow
awesome thank you so much and thank you
for the just kind of going over the high
level differences between our studio
as it exists on your desktop and our
studio workbench as well i think
sometimes we get so used to working with
it that we
forget a bunch of people may not even
have heard of our studio workbench
connect or package manager
before too
i see somebody asked on slido can i
publish an application with
i'm gonna i'm not sure if i pronounce
this right ipi widgets to allow
collaborators to change settings and
re-run the notebook
so
not currently so right now jupiter um
the jupiter support and connect is like
limited to which you think it was the
static document model right so there's
no running python process behind the
document um
i know that that's uh that's something
where we're thinking about in terms of
trying to make sure we're supporting the
full range of python sort of
interactive use cases but uh right now
if you deploy a notebook um then you can
do sort of the client-side interactivity
i illustrated earlier but sort of
interacting with the running python
process isn't supported today
thank you
and then i see someone else asked on
youtube
um is vs code just on the latest version
of our studio workbench because i think
they have workbench but they don't have
that yet
so yeah vs code support would have gone
out uh in beta for like juliet rose
which was like 1.4.17
something uh we've since switched to
calendar versioning and you should
install the latest anyway um so if
you're if you're running a version
that's older than 1.4 um it's unlikely
that you have vs code um and i would say
that like the the more recent versions
or where that um that support is going
to be the best so if you're interested
in upgrading i would just sort of go for
the most recent version
and i'll just say maybe i shouldn't
share this email but i will anyways but
um
if you
are in that situation and wanted to
upgrade or have questions
you if you don't know who your account
representative is you can always just
reach out to sales
rstudio.com as well and they can just
connect you the right person
um one other question that's on slido is
is there a substantial difference in
configuration when setting up workbench
to allow editing on all the platforms
r or python or is that a fairly standard
setup
there is there's a little bit more
configuration to do um so
you know you go from just installing r
right to having to install python
and then the python packages that
support uh doing these different styles
of editing uh for jupiter uh for vs code
you're installing another uh kind of
binary so there are a few more steps um
it's it's not i think
terribly involved but it is there is
some additional uh work required to get
a an installation that's fully future
up and running and then you know if you
decide you want to
you know the there there may be
additional complexity depending on like
how many instances
you want to run of of workbench and if
you're trying to cluster them with
things like that
great thanks david
um i can keep going with questions but i
just want to make sure was there
something else you want to show us here
too no i'm i'm here all day
okay
yeah any our studio questions throw them
at us
um so somebody asked on youtube
just a clarification about our studio
team
and if that was the name for the triple
threat combo of workbench package
manager and connect and yes that is
absolutely correct
so our studio team
is our studio workbench package manager
and our studio connect
let's see are there other questions over
on youtube or on slido
someone asked anonymously what switches
are you using on your mechanical
keyboard
uh they are
excuse me they are kelly golds um
yeah i have a ergodox split keyboard and
kelly gold switches
i'm glad you can tell
thanks david
i have a question um
if somebody wanted to just try this out
and
maybe watching today and hadn't seen it
before what's the best way to to try
this out
uh to try out let's try out which
like to try out using python on our
studio workbench
yeah um
what is the best way to try i think like
there's a
there's probably a conversation to be
had with your or well i guess there's
two things one we have like a
a hosted evaluation that we can where we
spin up an environment that has
everything or most of the things that i
showed today configured uh and we can
drop you into that uh pretty easily to
give you a chance to experiment um
some of our so that i think that's
probably where i'd start if you uh were
interested in seeing whether it would be
a good fit for you with the hosted
evaluation
awesome
i just shared a link in the chat on
youtube as well if you ever just wanted
to schedule time to chat with the team
about it or just
talk a bit more about your team's use
case or any challenges you face too
let me
go over to slido and youtube and just
see if there's other questions just as a
reminder if you want to ask anything
anonymously you can use the slido link
as well
and so i'll just re-share
that link into youtube too
it's just
rstd dot io slash meetup dash questions
or feel free to just type it into the
youtube chat too
give people a few more
minutes here
david what's your favorite example
that highlights uh python that's on
solutions
on the solution site
um
i
hmm
do i have a favorite example uh
i love all my children equally this
isn't what i'm supposed to say
um
i i think like the
i was like i think the the reticulate
examples are kind of interesting um
there are a collection of different uh
there's a collection of several of them
um and i think you know for
there are often
like reticulate is sometimes a little
bit difficult to get configured
correctly but if you if you do get that
configuration correct um it's very
powerful because it stops you needing to
rewrite a lot of things right so there
we have
some examples there where i think
there's an image classification example
where the ui is written
basically in shiny and then the um
the image classification is being
handled by a pie torch model um
and so you know if you're if you're
trying to spare yourself um you know
i mean there are bindings to torch right
so it's not like you couldn't do
uh things in a single language stack but
if you do find yourself needing to go
that cross-language route then i think
the fact that connect makes it really
easy to deploy these reticulated things
is pretty nice
awesome and i know i asked that question
with just thinking that people would
know what the solution site is and i was
wondering if you would be able to just
share that with everyone on the screen
too just so they're aware of it let me
find what i'm actually talking about uh
so
yeah uh
we have a collection of different
resources um just ways of you know
summaries of like best practices or
problems we see people coming up up
against repeatedly we try to document
some of those things at
solutions.ourstudio.com
um and so
uh in this case the the image
classification uh
thing that i mentioned right where the
you have a shiny ui uh pie torch uh back
end i think this is a an example that i
think is an interesting way if you if
that's a problem you're confronting
thank you i love
i always love pointing to alex's bike
share example on here too even if it's
not necessarily a python example but
i love that it shows the whole workflow
too
yeah that's um yeah and we've actually
we've just updated that to you know take
advantage of some of the newer things
that are happening in our studio in
terms of uh
sort of how we think about building
documents uh what it looks like to
share pinned models in an easier way um
and so this this this
collection of examples
gives the end-to-end flow of say picking
up some data from
uh the apis provided by lyft for the
capital bike share in in dc
and then you know through the process of
i'm trying to understand how many bikes
will be available
at the the you know at the station of my
choosing at a given point in the day and
so we go through the exercise of trying
to model those things and showing you
how you can break that app down into a
bunch of different pieces and have those
pieces live on connect
awesome thank you
a few other questions on slido and one
was can our studio workbench be
integrated with google cloud
so like our studio workbench on gcp
it can yeah so you can run um
you could run then we have customers who
run um workbench in you know
oh gosh what are their vms called
uh
google compute engine right so if if you
have you know
if you need to run workbench and gc you
can do that um if you want to use the
launcher with gke that's an option for
you as well
um so yeah i mean the the requirements
for for workbench are really like you
need a linux server
and you need to be able to get access to
you need to install the r language on it
but you can you can run it pretty much
anywhere
awesome and someone just followed up
with is that the same with our studio
team
yeah yeah so all the the product the the
requirements for for all the products
there those are listed at
docslutterstudio.com but in general uh
as long as you're trying to install to
one of our supported linux distributions
it should be
pretty straightforward to get
them running
in in the cloud of your choosing
great and just to confirm because i
didn't read the whole question out
that could be either in the cloud or on
your own premise if your team prefers
that too yeah in your own data center uh
in
in google cloud on linux you know really
wherever you feel like putting it
great um let's see one other question
um someone just asked a very broad
question is c better or python for
problem solving
is c better or python
i i don't know who has that problem
right like oh should i write this in
python or c like congratulations if
that's your problem
um
no i yeah like
no that
sorry that's i think yeah they they
you can
you know python is python calls a lot of
c code you could write um
i think it's just it's a question of
like what you're comfortable programming
and if you're comfortable programming in
c uh and python and you want to know
like i don't i don't have an answer to
that question i can't write c
were there any questions that you really
thought we were all going to throw at
you today and we didn't ask
um
i thought someone was going to ask if
they had to use virtual environments and
the answer is yes you you always have to
use a virtual environment always
thanks david let me just go check one
more time to see if there are any other
questions that we missed
so last chance if you want to ask
anything feel free to ask in the youtube
chat here
or on the slider link
let's see
i will put a short plug in for something
that i'm very excited about um
so
i've been
at our studio for over four and a half
years and i used to be on the sales team
and i would so often meet with people
who
were trying to advocate for using our
studio at their company
and we're maybe running into roadblocks
or just didn't know how to work with it
or start those conversations
and so
we finally got to make this new site
which is rstudio.com
champion
and it is there to help you advocate for
data science whether that's r or python
at your organization so how to build a
business case
how to maybe grow a data science
community
um and meetups at your company or really
when someone your boss asks you like hey
who else in my industry is using this
to pull all the industry examples we
know of from meetups or webinars or blog
posts
and put those together too thank you for
pulling it up davis
but also how to kick off the
conversations with it as well
and so there's so many amazing people
from the community out there who have
shared tips here with us so this is all
because of them
but really if
if you're in that position
i would recommend that you go and check
it out too
awesome i put that link in the chat i do
see a few more questions on youtube so
i'll go ask those two
one was is it better to run a python
file from r or read in the functions
oh you might be muted
i'd say i'd say it's hard to give a
general
uh answer to that question
um
so it probably depends on what you're
trying to accomplish
okay
thank you and if you ever want to talk
to us about what you're trying to
accomplish
feel free to yeah that would be a that
would be a great question to like spell
it in more detail on community um
so yeah if you go to
community.ourstudio.com and you you ask
that question um
that that i think that would be a good
place to sort of get into a discussion
about like what what are you trying to
achieve and which of those workflows is
going to make the most sense
great thank you
i'm not sure if you will know the answer
to this question but i saw one i missed
earlier will the testing or posted
environment that you mentioned
for our studio team be available for the
admin workshop at the conference
i don't know if we've decided like we've
landed on exactly what the
infrastructure for the admin workshop is
going to look like yet so i don't know
okay
and then just a short plug for anyone
who is interested in checking out those
workshops
we do have the conference coming up july
25th through the 28th and i'll share
the link in the
zoom or sorry the youtube chat there too
but thank you so much david for
answering all of our questions and just
going with the flow here today
really appreciate it
thank you all so much for bearing with
us as well and jumping over
from one platform to another sorry for
the technical
difficulties there but we are all human
even after the best testing sometimes
this happens
so thank you all so much really
appreciate your time and all the great
questions as well
as a reminder
right when this event is over the
recording will be available here too
but thank you all and a huge thank you
to you david really appreciate it
thank you for having me
have a good rest of the day